aber ist doch eigentlich nur ein hamster
wieso hat nämlich jetzt blockiert
willkommen beim neuen video und zwar
dreht sich ja in der heutigen
gesellschaft ziemlich geht um social
media chatten neue leute kennenlernen
neue freunde finden neue liebespartner
finden halt auch zum teil und genau
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht hey warum
es einfach mal ein video darüber so
dinge die mädchen beim chatten falsch
machen ich könnte das video ist genauso
denn dinge die alle beim chatten falsch
machen aber da ich nur mit mädchen so
schreibe weil als junge wenn man die
hand mehr mädchen als jungen kann ich
halt nur sagen was mädchen meiner
meinung nach falsch machen das ist mein
wein es ist nicht unbedingt die meinung
aller anderen jungs aber ich denke schon
dass ein großteil der jungen diese
meinung zum großen teil vertreten kann
und es trifft natürlich auch nicht alles
auf jedes mädchen zu aber man wird halt
sehr oft damit konfrontiert und
konfrontiert konfrontiert so und deshalb
habe ich bock dazu ein video zu machen
wir fangen mit punkt eins viel spaß ach
ja wenn ihr bock auf 328 dann immer doch
nach oben kommentare lassen aber das
niveau ist immer am besten versteckte ja
wir vereinfachen punkt eins an und zwar
es gibt wirklich sehr sehr viele von
diesen mädchen die dich selber nennt mit
ihren interessen folgt aber die jugend
nicht einfach kein stück unter denkt
irgendwann reicht's sommer oder nicht
ich meinen schlaf dabei sein das sieht
so aus meistens dann aber ich will auch
nicht unfreundlich seiner unmöglich
rüberkommen man anfängt dann halt immer
so guckt mal kurz gefasst stammen meine
in meiner freizeit reite ich zum
beispiel gerne also auf erden okay aber
ich liebe pferde so über alles okay toll
ich mag fußball spielen
ich habe sogar zwei eigengefährdung ich
hab sogar zwei und wie heißen die
der eine heißt schon teil und die andere
heißt kevin und käse
hallo
doch da
machen wir weiter mit punkt 2 und zwar
schon länger diese sprachnachricht
notizfunktion und wenn man glas oder
weißen mädchen kennen zu lernen und spaß
nachrichten sendet und dann das sowas
kommt habe ich immer an ok angst ist
vielleicht ein falsches wort aber das
kommt mal voll komisch rüber ich denke
mir dann so warum schickst du mir das
jetzt könntest du das nicht vielleicht
oder dieses geräusch schicken oder ohne
irgendwelche abstoßenden und erotischen
laute damit meine ich dass hier
eigentlich auch zu weit wir uns gut
die antwort war ganz schön schnell es
war das denn jetzt hilfe ja und dann
sind wir schon bei punkt nummer drei und
zwar schon öfter mal in meinem video
gesagt ja wenn jetzt als mädchen so
interesse bei den jungen wecken wollte
dann antwortet nicht immer direkt aber
whatsapp hat ja auch diese blauen
häkchen die mich richtig nerven
eingeführt so und wenn ihr dann in der
haid von dem jungen bekommt da
vielleicht aus versehen drauf kommt und
weil diese blauen häkchen kommen ihr
aber eigentlich noch gar nicht antworten
wollte dann antwortet aber bitte weil es
gibt auch mädchen die antworten da nicht
und das ist dann irgendwie auch ein
bisschen behindert oder nicht sondern
sie das nachher bei dem jungen songs wie
bei mir
und dann sind wir auch schon bei punkt
immer viel glaube und zwar wenn man
jetzt halt so junge mädchen sich so rath
kennenlernt dann schreibt er eigentlich
über jeden scheiß und wirklich jeden
scheiß aber es gibt auch diese art von
mädchen die dann halt direkt dem jungen
ihre ganze lebensgeschichte erzählen mit
irgendwelchem schicksalsschläge und man
weiß nicht was man oder ich weiß ja nie
was ich darauf antworten soll das sieht
dann manchmal so aus also jetzt hier auf
dieser seite ist der junge das bin ich
und hier ist das mädchen gleich also ich
fange jetzt mal wie das aussehen könnte
wie geht's dir heute so fragezeichen na
ja es geht so ich muss immer an meinen
hamster denken der vor zwei wochen
verstorben ist aber scheiße was
schreibst du denn jetzt
das tut mir total leid aber ist doch
eigentlich nur ein hamster kann ich das
jetzt so abschicken
mach einfach und nun dürfen hallo
wieso hat nämlich jetzt blockiert checke
ich nicht ich weiß nicht ihr könnt auch
alle diese situation und man weiß dann
halt nicht passt euch jetzt schreiben
reicht dann tut mir leid oder noch
irgendwas einwohner und jahr
ich hatte eben schon gedacht wenn ihr
bock auf teil zwei haben dann lass auf
jeden fall noch nach oben da würde mich
sehr freuen ansonsten sollte man kurve
alles schön eingebildet hier oben könnt
ihr mich verfolgen wenn ihr lust haben
so in der video beschreibung auch noch
mal verlinkt ansonsten jetzt hier oben
links weiter mit meinem letzten video
das war letzten mittwoch die lustigsten
beziehungs-aus beziehungs entdeckt das
auf jeden fall ab wir sehen uns am
mittwoch wieder in zwei tagen tag auch
und bäm